[Music]
my name is Carlos worthless but you know
the drone community I'm known as Chaput
it's almost like a superpower is this
complete freedom
[Music]
I'm not a really competitive person I
don't like to have that feeling like I
want to beat this guy prefer just
enjoying and they kind of like freestyle
of it
[Music]
now he's younger I used to do a lot of
extreme sports a lot of skating
snowboarding 10 years ago I have an
injury climbing and I completely broke
my leg and I have a few surgeries in my
legs I wasn't able to kind of do those
things anymore
I discovered drawn a 3d flying and
slowly I realized that I was getting the
same adrenaline you been doing this
without the danger
[Music]
it feels like an out-of-body experience
and it almost feels like you're inside a
complete different animal you're not a
human anymore
[Music]
I've been doing the drawing stuff and
posting videos online probably for a
couple of years I never got so much
attention it's pretty amazing I never
expected anything like this to happen we
were flying today it's a little
dangerous why because there's a lot of
metal I got stuck right there let's see
if I reach it's the problem with
frequency you know and the interference
that all of these metal bars create the
view that I can see on my goggles
sometimes gets a little fuzzy because of
all of these metals and it creates lines
[Music]
[Applause]
god ah easy it Tilikum let's find a
rhythm something kinky like this model
is nobody the same but it's like
this is a little scary they're not toys
you know there's a model in it that
spins really fast it has four propellers
that's in really fast so obviously if
you put your thing in me that's going to
cut you so it's important to know you
know it's fun is important to kind of
respect it okay back up to that I fly it
is called a sharp ooh X completely
designed for my taste
and it flights really amazing
[Music]
it's amazing to go to events and have
everybody kind of stopping you to say
like Amen thank so much because of your
video I start fine every time I hear
that it just makes you want to fly more
I definitely see it as an art form as a
way of recording is something that is
not easy to see something that you don't
see every day all right a way of seeing
an environment in a completely different
perspective
[Music]
[Applause]